senator Doug Jones from the state of
Alabama
you know the the one who recently beat
Roy Moore he responded recently to the
fact that Republicans are saying well we
just armed teachers and we even have
some police officers saying we should
armed teachers to prevent tragedies like
this from ever happening again
Doug Jones came out and said what most
of us are thinking and that is that this
is the dumbest idea I've ever heard
my wife is a teacher it's not her job to
go grab a gun that she has I guess
hidden somewhere in a room maybe kept on
her under this Republican idea and go
start shooting people her job is to
educate children to make their lives
better to prepare them for the world
that's what all teachers jobs are it's
not their job to go out and act like
vigilantes if somebody walks into a
school with a weapon of war furthermore
what happens when you suddenly don't
just have one person shooting but you
have 20 you're gonna end up with even
more death and destruction what happens
when police officers walk into a school
and there's ten different people
shooting do you think the police
officers are gonna be discriminate when
it comes to taking out whoever they
perceive to be the bad guy no the
research is 100% clear on this more guns
equal more death that is not disputable
that is a fact
more guns equals more death so yeah Doug
Jones is a hundred percent right here
arming teachers is the dumbest idea that
we could possibly come up with
that's like solving drunk driving by
saying well if you get so drunk that you
black out you can't get behind the wheel
no not how it works we're not going to
solve our gun addiction with more guns
and the other part of it who's gonna pay
for those I mean the average teacher in
the United States spends twelve hundred
dollars out of pocket
every single year on supplies for their
own room because schools are so
desperately underfunded in the United
States so who's gonna pay for the guns
for the teachers who's gonna pay for the
training for these teachers to learn how
to even use these things Republicans
love to just say that hey more guns more
guns right because that's what the NRA
wants that's gonna make them more money
because the NRA is funded by the gun
manufacturers so if they can push for
more guns those gun manufacturers sell
more their profits go up along with the
coffin makers to their profits are going
way up right now and that's what this is
about
every talking point we've seen coming
out of these pro weapon of war folk is
to the benefit of the gun manufacturers
they are the only ones who profit from
this and that is why we've got to do
something about it we have to put the
lives of American citizens of our
children ahead of the profits of
Industry unfair and cousins I'm sitting
in for David Pakman today you can follow
me on twitter at baron balance you can
also find me on youtube youtube.com
slash d ring of fire and we'll be right
back
today's program is sponsored in part by
fruit or the tor is a social forecasting
game where players come together and
compete with each other to predict
future events you open up the game on
your phone or web browser you'll see a
whole range of forecasts covering topics
across the board politics sports so much
more you wager on predictions about real
world events using food tours in game
fake currency and you earn more of this
currency every time you make a
prediction that comes true you can show
off your prediction skills to friends
improve your forecasting ability I'm
even on futur you can find my account by
clicking the link in the description if
you're watching this on YouTube and this
week on futur I posed the question will
robert molars trump russia investigation
end during this year during 2018 what do
you think
place your bets and you can sign up now
at futurecom and start making your
forecasts on political topics and so
many other topics it's free and it's
available on both Android and iOS as
well as on web browsers
that's fut you you are calm